yeah market segmentation is probably at
the very very center of go to market
strategy that's successful so first
let's talk about what it was a market
segment so a market segment is a group
of people that have two things in common
one is a use case they have a common set
of needs that they would be fulfilling
through a product like yours or someone
else's and secondly and this is the one
people miss they talk to each other so a
segment is actually a unit of
conversation and therefore and the
reason why that's so important is that
if you can get your marketing message
circulating inside a segment the segment
will circulate it for you know
entrepreneur can afford to go out and
pay to address every prospect that they
want to sell to you have to have your
community selling for you but that means
you have to be able to model the
boundaries of that community and be able
to aim your marketing communications
activities in a way that that community
embraces them and it resonates inside
that community so just to make that
point crystal-clear when you talk about
your product you're saying things that
apply to many communities that will not
resonate inside a community when you
talk about the specific needs of that
community in the language that community
talks to itself about even when you're
not talking about you now you're gonna
resonate with that community so so the
market segmentation in that sense is a
communications vehicle to make sure you
talk the talk of the customer so that
they can then walk the walk with you if
you can go and going forward that's good
idea number one the second thing about
market segmentation and this is kind of
a fun experience you have with you've
been marketing for a while fun if you
like learning with pain so the idea is
whenever you draw a think about a
segment people usually like they draw a
circle and they say okay so we're
targeting this segment and then
inevitably somebody comes along and says
well what about this customers right at
the edge of the circle
and almost since I'm not quite and the
way I okay we'll bring them in too and
then we'll bring these people in here
and then we'll bring it pretty soon
there's just there's no integrity of the
process at all so what we've learned
about segments is you cannot define a
segment from it by its boundary because
whatever you draw a line there'll be
somebody just on the other side of that
line whose pretty darn close to the
segment right so what you do instead is
you define segments by their center
points will you do this is where they
get this idea called the poster child
the poster child is the perfect exemplar
the the ideal representation of the
target customer with the compelling
reason to buy and that that person it's
an often you make a you create something
that they call a persona which would be
the the embodiment of that target
customer and then you aim all of your
marketing communications at that one
person because they it resonates with
all the people around them and
furthermore you get your engineering and
you name a mall of your engineering at
solving the use case exactly the way
that customer would like it solved and
again that engineering will resonate
with people around and so therefore you
can act on the world in units of use
cases in in word-of-mouth groups and so
segmentation is designed to allow you to
leverage engineering to the point where
it where the world is on your side as
soon as you go outside the use case and
as soon as you go outside the
conversation group the world is no
longer working with you they may not be
working against you but they're not
working with you and as an entrepreneur
at the beginning you desperately need
the work world to work with you
eventually if you become a global
standard then you don't need
conversation groups nobodies Google does
not need a conversation group it is a
global standard but most of us are not
Google and so particularly the beginning
and even at the beginning Google was not
Google so so so how do you get started
with those early groups